you came to LA 2728 ish anybody under 30
feels that pressure to make it before 30
mm and I think I feel like now even more
so mm-hmm can you talk about that and
how you are now in that opinion and what
you tell some of your students yeah you
know it's I've learned the difference
between men and women when it comes to
birthdays it's really funny every guy at
a certain age has this mental meltdown
when their birthday approaches because
they haven't accomplished what they've
wanted to accomplish in life we're gonna
different you guys will go out you deal
with it in a different way they'll go
shopping there buy some shoes they'll
work it out they figure it out guys have
a mental meltdown we we just we can't
handle it because you know a man is
typically in him in his own thinking
judged by his achievements by his
accomplishments and we all unfortunately
do that to ourselves we plan out our
life and you've heard people say I
didn't think I'd be here I thought I'd
be so much further and for me when I had
that epiphany when I had that meltdown I
think I went into this place of saying
to myself okay well if that's not what's
happening now what am I supposed to do
and like I said you keep going you know
the hardest part is to keep going but I
think with most people having that
understanding of okay you know life is
what it is it's not it's not what I want
it to be it's what it's going to be and
I'm all okay with that am i okay with
you know being this age and not having
this but I did start to entertainment
industry a little later
I have actors in my class they started
in their teens and they're doing great
now you know actors and people that I've
worked with when I met them at 19 and
they're doing phenomenal now you know
big agents and two or three TV shows and
stuff but I firmly believe that if it
wasn't supposed to happen until 50 it's
not gonna happen into a 50 so there's
nothing you can do about it and to me
the growth is accepting that really
really really accepting that
that's what my epiphany was was like
okay it's not supposed to happen this
way are you okay with that and moving
from there and I think once people do
that it's that's the true level of faith
of knowing that this is what you're
supposed to be doing there there is no
falsehood in it it's just the thing of a
matter of time okay what if you're okay
with it and you've worked on yourself
enough where you're okay
but you're getting all these little
voices from here and there and and it's
your 30th birthday I mean I'm past 30
but I remember that pressure and for me
30 was actually wonderfully freeing I
was in a rare situation where I was
getting out of a bad situation
so I felt good but I know a lot of
people feel this weird pressure mm-hmm
you talk about this pressure from
outside yourself what if you're worked
on yourself but outside I honestly I
never really had that pressure once once
and if I did if it was going to be it
was gonna be for my mom because you know
my mom is one of my driving forces but
she's my number one fan she's my biggest
fan so it never it never came to that
point now there were always people
around me accomplishing that's a
different pressure that I put on myself
seeing other people get there and
wondering why I'm not that's always like
if anyone says it that doesn't bother
them they're lying
that's the narcissism that's who you are
as actors and entertainers like you know
you want to be doing just as great as
somebody else it's not competition it's
just a thing of I'm talent this person
is talented I should be there as well
life isn't fair and in any circus either
you know I think once I realized that
that quote once I realized that I things
got easier for me so there was never
really any outside pressure for that in
regards to me there was always the fear
of am I ever gonna make it am I ever
gonna get there am I ever gonna be able
to do this and I have that's always a
fear because you know your battle in
life you're battling time time is the
most precious gift that's given to you
and you know you're hoping that man by
the time I'm this age I want to meet
with do this and
you know but listen if you're not doing
what you love get out and find out what
that is and if you are doing what you
love but you're hearing or even no one's
saying it - but you just turn on Twitter
and the top 30 of 30 25 under 25 so then
the media is telling you that you're not
okay yeah but you know times are
different I mean back then when I when I
was just acting it was a different time
than it is now I mean there's people in
their 60s and 70s becoming stars
overnight sensations and stuff it I
listen I tell my actors all the time
like if your family or people are not
only your crew then why should they be
then when you finally get blessed
because it's going to happen and I do
tell people the only reason why I won't
happen is if you quit
it won't happen there's a there's a
definitive thing that happens if you
quit you don't make it that's just
there's this it's night and day it's
black and white
you quit you don't make it you stay in
the game it's a numbers game you will
get there now the level of what you get
to is primarily on your understanding of
the business and how much you want to
give over of who you are your commitment
but you know unless your mom or your dad
is doing sound and you know holding the
boom mic and you know picking up
sandbags and stuff if they're they don't
have a right to say anything about your
career if they're not doing that if
they're really really behind you and
supporting you
I can understand hearing their voices
but if they're not even doing that if
they're not supporting you by it sending
money or you know playing tickets when
they want you to come home and all that
stuff why would you even listen um
honestly
you